bonsoir
mesdames bonsoir messieurs bonne année à
toutes et à tous sur la proposition du
Premier ministre chargé de la
planification écologique et
énergétique le président de la
République a
nommé Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté Indri et
numérique monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
Maes Madame Catherine
Vautrin ministre du
Travail de la santé et des
solidarités madame Amélie oua
Castera ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports et
des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques monsieur Marc
fenau ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire madame Rachida
Dati ministre de la
Culture monsieur Sébastien le
Cornu ministre des
Armées monsieur Éric Dupont
Moretti garde des saau ministre de la
justice monsieur Stéphane
séjourné ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires
étrangères monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoire madame Sylvie
retaillot ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la
recherche sont nommé ministre
délégué auprès du Premier
ministre madame Priska
t chargée du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement madame Marie
Lebec chargée des relations avec le
Parlement madame Aurore berger chargée
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes et de la lutte contre les
discrimination le président de la
République réunira l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement pour un conseil
des ministres qui se tiendra demain
vendredi 12 janvier à
11h je vous
remercie